leader with us is gulok behem te
kochinova i'm sure i messed that up but
i'm gonna go with that
welcome begin
that game
i don't know how you saved it
your thoughts
after finishing such a game what a
turnaround
that was
i was actually hoping that she could she
could miss this idea that was the only
help that i have i completely forgot
that she's coming just rook a
h3 because after night after even knight
e4 i was
going to take on e4 i thought that's the
only chance because i felt like my
position was losing already
but then after i missed it i said okay
this is the only idea i have and i'm
gonna try it
uh we have it here
on the screen
you so you saw this coming when you
sacrificed the exchange as a possibility
you saw the rooks doubling you must have
just known though no i totally forgot
that idea that rookie
i'm totally like losing there
i'm not on time to protect everything
that i have so you were aware that this
was going but how are you playing so
quickly at this point it seemed like you
just figured
the game is over i'm just making i just
don't give up uh
like early
if i'm gonna resign i will just do it
immediately if i'm gonna play i just
play it until the end
you had such a bad
don't know what to position
we were shocked
i'm shocked as well i'm like wait a
second what's going on there
you know
from the opening i was struggling whole
game and at some point i i played a5
instead of a6 i don't know we had like
time trouble
it was a huge time trouble so i had to
move something i had 15 seconds and of
course a6
makes a lot more sense there i don't
know why i thought maybe she has some b4
so i'm just protecting from it but after
the time control i start to realize that
my position is still bad and i have the
weakness on a5 too you know
it was just very hard to play
and at some point i just blundered
when you win a game like this one what's
the feeling
is it like you know well you answer the
question i mean it's uh for me it's
always hard to start the tournament i'm
even against low-rated players sometimes
i make a draw or i can't even lose for
skins so i was lucky i'm happy about
that
all right i hear you what a comeback
comeback of the round as far as we can
tell congratulations and hope you're
warm now keep uh winning games
begum a quick question
did her resignation surprise you uh
weren't you expecting that she would
play queen d6 chat yeah i thought she's
gonna play queen d6 d2 is not a good
move actually no
i don't know why i i thought that i'm
going rook d1 and knight d4 after knight
f3 she cannot take it back because of
rook d3 check
right that was my idea that's why i
played the
like
but the king goes to a force
we was very extremely tired to be honest
and then after the year you expected
that this was going to be a check yeah
just game over and then after detail i
realized that something is wrong but she
resigned i'm like okay
that's so good we both were so tired we
had like twice uh time trouble it was
like it was very hard to play with a lot
of time
wow devastating game for her great for
you again congratulations thank you our
congratulations indeed